der fc bayern startet aufgrund vieler
ausfälle stark dezimiert in die
rückrunde gegen borussia mönchengladbach
steht die revanche für das pokal debakel
trotzdem auf der to-do-liste robert
lewandowski saisontreffer nummer 20 der
pole hat einfach ein dauerabo auf die
torjäger kanone die gäste mit nur einem
punkt aus den letzten fünf spielen
wirkten nach der winterpause wie
ausgewechselt florian neuhaus ausgleich
27 minute schlecht verteidigt kimmig bei
seinem comeback als rechtsverteidiger
aufgebotenen unglücklich beim
klärungsversuch
nur vier minuten später ist die
defensive wieder nicht auf der höhe
stefan einer mit dem siegtreffer
gladbach gewinnt am ende glücklich
2022 fängt für die bayern richtig
bescheiden
vorlage für borussia dortmund das in
frankfurt einen ganz schweren auftakt
vor der brust hat der bvb ist besser die
gastgeber aber effizienter raphael burri
verwandelt den ersten torschuss in der
15 minute der kolumbianer ist bei der
sge der aufkommende torjäger erster
bundesliga doppelpack und der sechste
saisontreffer insgesamt schwarz-gelb
beweis im zweiten durchgang moral der
eingewechselte tolga nasa mit dem
anschlusstreffer in der 71 minute
dortmund wird in der schlussphase immer
stärker und bläst zur aufholjagd so
penning hamm aufschlags
die eintracht findet keine entlastung
motor hut dafür die lücke 89 10 minute
die krönung eines mentalen kraft das
spiel gedreht den abstand auf die bayern
auf sechs punkte verkürzt nach drei
siegen in serie ist der hessische
höhenflug beendet vielleicht wird die
meisterschaft ja doch noch mal spannend
der tabellendritte der hinrunde ist
nicht leipzig oder leverkusen sondern
der sportclub aus freiburg das auch weil
kein team so gefährlich ist bei
standards wieder fällt bekommt das
bereits in der sechsten minute zu spüren
janika mit der führung dem
abstiegskandidaten fehlt es an
stabilität björn joggen zu beginn der
zweiten halbzeit zwei zu null bielefeld
kommt nochmal masa ogawa und der bittere
fehler von marktflecken vertreter
benjamin uphoff der 28 jährige feiert
sein bundesliga debüt und das wird er so
schnell nicht vergessen drehen lassen
wir und das 2 2 in der 85 minute
unglücklicher
leipzig gegen mainz spielerisch ein
vielversprechendes duell die gäste ab
der 20 minute allerdings in unterzahl
deniz aytekin schickt alexander hug
wegen handspiels mit rot vom platz ein
blackout des verteidigers der seinen
trainer bo svensson zur verzweiflung
bringt andere silber übernimmt den
fälligen strafstoß
leipzigs topskorer in kuh kommt erst zur
zweiten halbzeit um dann richtig
aufzudrehen vorarbeit für dominik buss
leipzig branche die rheinhessen mit
einem lebenszeichen des soli nur noch
eins zu zwei die große show gehört aber
in kongo der franzose trifft erst in der
58 minute und zeigt sich nach seiner
krone infektion schon wieder in topform
kurz darauf leitete er den schlusspunkt
ein doppelpack silva skore hattrick
endpunkten leipzig feiert einen
gelungenen rückrundenstart
platz 4 gegen 7 in leverkusen die
werkself hat mehr ballbesitz mehr
chancen und das ziel schliesslich auch
die verdiente führung patrick 38 minute
saisontreffer 17 für den schächten kurz
vor der halbzeitpause heißt es dann alle
gegen lukas radetzky bayerns nummer eins
taucht hier erst klasse ab und pariert
den kopfball weltklasse ist dann aber
gegen grieth prömel chancenlos und jung
berlin mit einem schmeichelhaften dafür
spektakulären ausgleich im zweiten
durchgang kommen die gäste mit mehr zug
vors tor kruse wunderbar auf engstem
raum wieder prügel erster bundesliga
doppelpack für den 27 jährigen die
gastgeber brauchten einige zeit um in
die partie zurückzufinden 84/10 minute
nach vorarbeit von bellarabi oder tantal
mit dem ausgleich
haben starke hoffenheimer empfangen
auswärtsstarke augsburger die gäste mit
einem traumstart michael gregoritsch
fünfte minute drittes saisontor alle per
kopf augsburg führt hat aber mit dem
tempo der gastgeber große probleme das
baby aus dax kurz vor weihnachten hat
der angreifer seinen vertrag bei der tsg
bis 2026 verlängert und das gibt
natürlich selbstvertrauen spiel gedreht
vor der halbzeitpause der zweite
durchgang ist ereignisarm bis zur
nachspielzeit david raum 3 1 hoffenheim
nun seit sieben spielen ungeschlagen
greuther fürth gegen stuttgart
unvorstellbar aber nach so vielen toren
hat der achtzehnte spieltag tatsächlich
auch eine nullnummer dabei hat der
tabellenletzte mit branimir guter eine
riesenchance keeper florian müller aber
auch riesige reflexe auch der vfb ist im
kellerduell nah dran an einem treffer
diese bogenlampe weiß sascha burchert
aber noch zu entschärfen eine
punkteteilung die keinem so wirklich
weiterhilft
der karneval ist in der hauptstadt
hertha bsc hat den ersten fc köln zu
gast die kölner mit ihrem gewohnten
flanken gewitter halbe stunde gespielt
anthony modeste zwölf saisontore neun
per kopf köln hat einen kopfball über
her zwei minuten später wieder eine
flanke wieder gefahr und rede da der fc
feiert eine schöne auswärtsfahrt berlin
kann die partie lange nicht dämpfen 57
10 minute bleiben wieder ein langer sehr
langer freistoß
hertha wirft alles nach vorne der reader
hat probleme den ball zu klären jan
tillmann spaziert zur entscheid
köln hat die gute form über die
winterpause gehalten feiert den dritten
sieg in serie
der vfl wolfsburg hat die vergangenen
sieben pflichtspiele allesamt verloren
und beim aufsteiger vfl bochum kommt
noch eine niederlage dazu - pantelic mit
dem siegtreffer in der 65 spielminute
für florian kuwait und wolfsburg heißt
es neues jahr altes leid
die ergebnisse des 18 spieltags in der
übersicht die bayern kassieren gegen
gladbach ii ihre dritte
saison-niederlage
leverkusen und union teilen sich die
punkte dortmund mit beeindruckende
aufholjagd in frankfurt dadurch ist es
wieder ein bisschen spannender an der
tabellenspitze der bvb nur noch sechs
punkte hinter den bayern
hoffenheim springt auf platz 3 und köln
darf tatsächlich von der champions
league träumen der abstiegskampf
verspricht in der rückrunde eine enge
angelegenheit zu werden zwischen platz
elf und 17 sind es nur sechs punkte
kräuter führt weiter abgeschlagen am
tabellenende
[Musik]